so I'm going to Lunge for those biceps
right away okay I lunge and I have to be
able to come up do you see in one
movement not going to
go okay you have to figure out where
your masses that you can do this okay
and then you climb
so grab
me you see you're pushing down okay and
now you're going to pry but you got to
take away that base okay and you have to
take tension away so it
slips you
see show you what I
mean okay there's a lot of tension I'm
holding them up in my legs okay
well I start bringing this in from its
leverage point and then I just kind of
relax do you see that did you feel it I
don't have to do it long I have to
reduce the
friction that comes from the tension do
you get it otherwise I got to push a lot
as opposed to just clear the
leg and control the leg for the
homolateral knee slice got it so I go
one up two it's
done okay I'm on I'm
low and I
secure okay I'm not letting go of that
hook and I'm not letting go of this hook
here okay my weight is on him so he
moves
whatever it's not so
easy okay and I'm loading this leg you
feel that okay and then I'm going to do
the same thing so I load the leg what's
he want to do
yes and I do the same thing on the other
side secure the
B got it yes
sir when I say I do the same thing is I
release the tension the friction will go
away and it just slips on
okay try again okay so what we're
working on is that release of of tension
okay that you you you use it so I'm
coming up boom release down I go and
he's he's not going to just let me die
for that you see okay so a couple things
to
realize you just want one frame do
whatever you whatever you okay so he has
two frames there you see okay the first
thing to realize is that his strength is
in his elbows this part of his arm okay
stay there here is where he's very
strong but here he's not very strong he
had he made the mistake of putting his
hands together so when I drop it over
here do you see you have it and now I
can come into that same
technique okay so let's go to for I'm
here here you framed don't you're going
to want to push on that don't push on it
don't push there yield there yield there
and then the other shoulder comes down
you go on the
hands and then you come
in
okay that's why like when he's up
up your your power is not in your hand
it's in the this upper arm your upper
arm is where
okay the upper arm the
upper okay got
it let's try it
again
okay you you could always knock it off
but I want you to to learn the yielding
okay see his fingers right
here just like his hands are to his
elbows his fing fingers are to his wrist
okay so what I'm going to do is go
around it this
way can you guys see that yes sir okay
and I'll back
step
around and then you're right yeah lot of
times you get that wrist lock so be
careful shouldn't have done it that
fast it's this wrist
Lo same
move there it is just come around this
way and find side from side control
you'll have that protected all right
just drive it up and
over and we're back
over
okay we go